[موسيقى]
بعد عام يعني هلا في الفتره هذه احنا
ابتدا يعني بعد ضغط مني او مساعده من عده
نواب امريكان بالسنه
تمكنا من اقناع وزاره العدل بفتح تحقيق في
مقتل شيرين واختيالها
وهذا ابتدا بشهر
نوفمبر 2022 لسه في بدايته يعني بقدر اقول
تحقيق ماشي
التحقيقات عده صارت سبعه وثمانيه تحقيقات
انعملت كلها كانت التحيات هذه عمله في
مكان الحدث من مكان الحدث
وكانت تعتمد على حقائق
وقرائن يعني شهود عيان
تسجيلات من مكان الاغتيال
[موسيقى]
كل التحقيقات هاي زي ما قلت اثبتت انه
شيرين ارتدت على يد قناص اسرائيلي ما في
جدال في هالموضوع هذه كلها بتساعدنا لما
نوصل للقضاء للمحاكم انه هادي بدها تكون
دليل عنا انه صحيح التم الاغتيال عن يتقل
ناس اسرائيلي هلا هم بقولوا بديوا انه هذا
عن غير عنده هاي ولكن يعني في في عنا احنا
كمان
الامور مهمه بتثبت انه لا كان عن سبق
اصرار وترسب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ما في شيء راح يرجع شيرين للاسف ولكن اهم
شيء انه
سياسه الاغتيالات اللي بتتبعها بتتبعها
الاحتلال تتوقف اسرائيل والاحتلال
الاسرائيلي عم بيغتال يومي فلسطينيين
صحفيين مدنيين ما في اي احد يحاسب ما في
اي رقيب وهذا اهم شيء انه يتوقف اذا هذا
الشيء توقف بكون في تحقيق العداله لكثير
من الفلسطينيين اللي استشهدوا من غير ما
حتى ينفتح تحقيق في اغتياله
[موسيقى]